Fresh wie ein Monday, das Ufo ist back Ich rapp für Fanta und für Florentin Delft Ich rapp für Fanta so wie Smudo und Beck Ich rapp für Fanta so wie Julien Bam Heute, wo ich schnell mit dem Fleur und dem wir haben ein Team Werbaut wie ein Pimp und das dem Morning im Dram Die Garde gleich die Kaufswelle mit Comedy-Kelter in der Podcast wie Blockbuster Hollywood-Full Beste Früste an die Fette und den Stefan-Pietze als den Byzantiten, die die Show-Rands nicht auf Netflix streamen Netzt sich jetzt aus Bett und und bacht den Schlepp der Bahn und exig als die Kühlte im Attewerk und zweck dich schnell ein Lass-e-Kür-Check. Darf dir jetzt nicht die überteuerten Nöte, um unser gut und holle Schütz für die treuesten Fans? Lorentine, Feuer wie ein Feuerwehrmann, ja, uns bringt gleich die Hütte, auch wenn Häuser nicht brennen. Stefan, rollt'n J-Wett und macht Netflix in J-M, es ist wie ein Film, seit wann es geht nur ums Drehen, Hannes, sie mischt Willi den Exosy-Pillen, ja, Sky so lecker, er kam mit ein bisschen Ketchup, das ist circa das Biggerpix, also wie das Bild vom Tetzler. Hey, ho, das kam plötzlich. Hey, ho, herz Willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid mit diesem ganz fantastischen Intro von P-P-P-P-Potkasufo mit Steve Tietz und Will V. Ja, und das war gerade Eisbär. Vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Experiment. Und sehr, sehr clevere Lyrics. Ist er ein Star? Er ist ein Star. Ist Eisbär ein Star? Ja, ja, absolut. Seine Lyrics sind fast ausgestorben. Weil die so gut sind. Ist Eisbär so wie I-C-E geschrieben oder wie Eis? Nein, I-C-E, Eisbär. Ja. So. Und ja. Wir sind wie so, wir nehmen wirkliche Coolness raus aus dem Intro, indem wir den abmoderieren wie so WDR-Moderatoren.
So, das war jetzt Eisbär, Eis geschrieben wie das englische Wort Eis.
Naja, das war dieses Hip-Hop.
Das war ein sogenannter Hip-Hop-Song.
Cloud Rap.
Das Album erscheint kommenden Montag und wurde vom Foyetan bereits abgefeiert.
Ich könnte was zum Inhalt sagen, wenn ich auch nur eine einzige Silbe verstanden hätte, was nicht der Fall war, aber langfetzig. Bestimmt frech auch, keck, aber keck wurde übrigens jetzt einfach neu beschrieben. Keck war ja immer so wie frech, so ein Altbackenbord, mittlerweile ist es ja durch diese Internet-Hahaha-Bewegung. Achso, du meinst K-E-K. K-E-K, neu besetzt. Das kannst du aber kaum noch unterscheiden. Keg und Keg. Kann man nicht mehr unterscheiden. Ich habe eine ganz fantastische Dokum gesehen. Ja. Und vom Paper the Frog. Den kennst du ja in Sicherheit, Paper the Frog. Ein sehr bekannte Internet-Meme von diesem weirden, traurig aussehenden Frosch, das ja im Internet aufgetaucht ist, bei Forteändern irgendwann, und dann nach und nach immer mehr zu einem rechten Symbol wurde, weil es von der so einer Alt-Right-Bewegung genommen wurde und instrumentalisiert wurde. Und diese Doku heißt Feels Good Man, das war das erste Meme von diesem Frosch, der, glaube ich, mit ganz heruntergelassenen Hosen pinkelt. Und darüber war die, das war so eine Comic-Buchreihe, und dann fragt ein anderer Mitbewohner, warum machst du das, warum ziehst du die Hose ganz runter, und er sagt, feels good, man. Und das war das Meme, was diesen Forsch berühmt gemacht hat. Und mittlerweile sind in den Sprechblasen halt vor allem Swastikas, muss man sagen. Man fragt sich, ey, wie das passiert Und diese Dokumentation hat glaube ich auch Sundance gewonnen als beste Dokumentation.
Also fantastisch, wie die vor allem den Erfinder, den Zeichner begleitet.
Hast du die gesehen, die Doku?
Nee, nee, ich habe schon mal einen Podcast darüber gehört, aber der Erfinder will ja damit gar nichts zu tun haben.
Du hast einen Podcast über den Erfinder, über den Film.
Über die Doku gesehen.
Über den, der die Doku gesehen hat.
Ich habe im Grunde diese Folge gehört.
Das fand ich bei den Knives Out auch so toll, das beste Zitat eigentlich. Ich habe einen Tweet über den Artikel gelesen. Das passt das Internet ganz gut zusammen. Man guckt selten das Original. Ja, aber da wurde er auch interviewt und der will ja gar nichts damit zu tun haben, mit dieser rechten Szene und kämpft dafür, dass er seine Comics möglichst menschenfreundlich und niedlich macht und so und dagegen zu arbeiten, was ich einen tollen Kampf finde einfach. Es ist so geil. Ringen um diesen Frosch. Wahnsinn und diese Geschichte ist so, ist verloren mittlerweile auch einfach, muss man sagen, also toller Kampf, aber halt leider vorbei, leicht verloren, weil jetzt auf dieses 12 zu 0 hinten, aber man gibt nochmal Gas, es gibt dieses Institut und motiviert in der Halbzeit nochmal. Also die Rede, aber der Trainer war schon, nee, es gibt nämlich dieses Institut in Amerika. Man motiviert in der Halbzeit noch mal. Ja, also die Rede, aber der Trainer war schon, ne, ne. Es gibt nämlich dieses Institut in Amerika, wo Hass-Symbol drauf landen, auf so einer Liste, die werden so indiziert. Dann darf man die nicht mehr benutzen. Das Weisse Haus. Oh, yes! Satire, Berg, Schlag, Hammer. Da ist er. Nein, wie heißt das? Abrissbirne. Okay. Die Satire-Abrissbirne. Danke. Ja, okay. Und da ist dann der Frosch drauf gelandet und das Ende des Films, kein großer Spoiler, ist auch eine Dokumentation, kann man Dokumentation spoilern, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls kommt er dann da hin und versucht dann noch diesen Frosch von dieser Liste zu bekommen, von diesen Hasssymbolen. Und er sagt, ja, ich habe hier mit The Frog doch gemalt, weil das ein Symbol von Freundschaft sein sollte.
Und der Typ so, ja, waren Sie einmal im Internet? It's a way, ist nicht mehr das. Und dann gibt es auch so super ernste Anhörungen von ihm, wie er dann zu dem Forst interviewt wird und was seine Intention waren, ihn zu machen, von diesem Institut. Und dann kam jemand die Frage, warum meinst du denn Pepe? Und er sagt, well, it sounded a bit like pee-pee. Und das ist mittlerweile so ein Symbol des Hasses. Einfach Hasses. Und es ist wirklich total interessant, auch ich finde es total gruselig, wie es funktioniert, in der Hinsicht, also dass du das Fortchern ist ist ja auch einfach so eine Seite, die ein bisschen dazu einlädt, so radikal zu werden so ein bisschen, weil die haben es so beschrieben als so Internet-Darwinismus, weil ja, das ist alles anonym, also alle fangen gleich an und dann geht es einfach darum, wer den meist geteilten Beitrag, den meist beantworteten Beitrag, da wird es glaube ich der Forchan-Weg. Und da muss es halt irgendwann lauter werden und krasser werden, sonst wird es ja nicht gehört. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Warst du da unterwegs bei Fortschern? Früher halt mal, so in dieser Jugendphase habe ich mich mal da so durchgeklickt, so, aber an sich nicht, ne. Weil es ist schon so ein Kram. Da gibt es aber auch ganz viele Unterboards und so, ich glaube, das ist nochmal nochmal ein Unterschied. Ich glaube, da gibt es dann auch so das Pferdeboard, wo man dann auch sehr nett miteinander redet über Pferde. Ja, ich glaube, es ist einfach eine Zeit, also die fangen alle nett an, glaube ich, und am Ende steht so eine Alt-Ride-Bewegung. Ich glaube, auch bei Pferden. Es fängt bei Pferden an, und dann gibt es so ein Fort-Chain-Forum drei Monate, und dann brauchen die ersten Swastikers auch. So kriegen die dich halt immer, über so ein harmloses Sailor Moon Forum,
und nach drei Wochen bist du halt ganz tief drin.
Schwierig.
Aber gut, dass wir, wir werden nämlich auch, glaube ich, mega radikalisiert worden davon,
aber wir haben Gott sei Dank bei Twitter angefangen.
Das stimmt.
Wir wurden Comedy radikalisiert.
Das stimmt eigentlich, ja.
Glück gehabt.
Ja, manchmal ist es einfach Glück gehabt.
Ja, und Twitter hat auch so, glaube ich, richtig gemacht, mit den Herzen.
Früher war es ein Sternchen, auch recht gealtert, unsere Folgen, wo wir darüber gesprochen mal gesprochen haben, dass es ein Sternchen war. Mittlerweile sind es ja Herzchen, ist lieber, netter alles. Finde ich gut. Finde ich toll. Viele, viele, viele gute Gags auf twitter.com, viele gute Gags schlummander. Das ist der Gag-Tipp der Woche, komm mal die Tipp der Woche, twitter.com slash was immer ihr wollt. Ja, machen wir mal ein Fragezeichen. Tippt mal einfach ein. Tippt mal Harald ein. Ein paar Wörter ein, mal gucken, was passiert. Kat, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, Kate, der einfach verschiedene Worte, tippt einfach mal wildkürlich ein. Man muss ja sagen, das Internet am Anfang, ich meine, es gab ja eine Zeit, wo es das Internet gab, aber keine Suchmaschinen. Das heißt, du warst selber die Suchmaschine. Die Tortuga, die Insel, die nur gefunden werden kann von Leuten, die über das wissen, wo sie liegt. Das heißt, du musst halt einfach ... We're back. Das heißt, du müsstest halt gucken, wie könnte ein Sailor Moon Forum heissen. Du bist auch bei Sailor Moon, okay. Und dann tippst du das halt ein und ... na gut, vielleicht anders, probierst du zehn Namen ein oder nein. Ist Google die Taschenlampe in der Dunkelheit des Internets? Google ist wie so ein Seil, an dem man sich herablassen kann. Oh, war das wieder der Satire-Florentin? Nein, das war der, ich weiß nicht, wie das Internet funktioniert, Florentin. Sorry, ich muss meine vielen Characters auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen ordnen. Ich brauche verschiedene Hüte, die ich aufsetzen kann, dass man weiß, wer ich gerade bin. Sortier die mal vielleicht. Ja, das Universum wird zu groß, zu viele Charaktere. Wir müssen ein paar sterben, wir brauchen so eine Red Wedding, wo wir einfach mal so ein paar alte Figuren einfach töten. Ja, genau. Ganja Stefan muss auch weg. Wir können auch mal so Hazel Brugger einladen, die so einen Cameo hat da bei uns und dann kurz alte Charaktere einfach killt. Ja, genau. Oder das ganze Universum war nur ein Traum von Hazel Brugger und wir machen eine Folge, wo Hazel Brugger aufwacht und sagt, oh, das war verrückt, und dann geht's normal, dann kann man so sagen, das ist das Universum resetten.
Der billigste, wie das bei GZS-Set oder andere Serie.
Die Busfolge. Anna und die Liebe wurden alle.
Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, also Leute, die nicht diese Comedy-Distanz haben wie wir, oder diese Vogelperspektive auf diesen Moment, haben sich sich auf die nächste Folge Alles, was zählt, so gefreut, und dann sind alle gestorben in einem Busunglück. Wo man immer schon skeptisch werden kann, wenn sämtliche Hauptfiguren in einem Bus sind. Nein, nicht in Zug, nicht. Also wirklich so ein Schiff mit Tyrion, Robert Baratheon, Robb Stark, alle sind auf einem Schiff und man denkt! What is happening here? Entweder das wird die fucking längste Dialogszene der Welt, Daenerys um die Ecke, alle drei Drachen stehen da, der Kleine, dann dieser Junge, der dicke Drache, der lustige Drache, der dicke Drache und der mit dem Hut. Alle drei, ja irgendwie muss man hier unterscheiden können, einer war halt ein bisschen dicker. Dann merkt man schon, oh das geht eine komische Richtung, aber ich glaube bei Roseanne war das so, dass die letzte Staffel nur noch geträumt wurde. Ich dachte kurz, welcher Charakter ist nochmal Roseanne von Game of Thrones? Nicht die Baby Roseanne. Ich glaube das war so, dass die letzte Staffel komplett geträumt wurde. Das war dann auch absurd, die haben dann im Lotto gewonnen und irgendwie so die normalen Story-Schablonen haben überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert, weil die alle reich waren und irgendwie keine Probleme mehr hatten. Und dann stellt sich raus, dass das alles nur geträumt war und eigentlich alle tot waren. Also ganz merkwürdig. Aber irgendwann in Staffel sieben oder so. Ja, ja, klar. Irgendwann denkst du dir auch einfach scheiß drauf, wir können einfach machen, was wir wollen. Ich glaube auch so, dass die Schwarzwaldklinik irgendwann rauskommt, dass dann irgendwie so der eine war ein Roboter die ganze Zeit und so und es wird so brutal absurd. Ich finde es geil, wenn es absurd werden würde. Ja, vor allem die denken sich so, ja, unsere alte Zielgruppe stirbt weg, jetzt können wir so die Rick and Morty Zielgruppe erschließen. Paralleluniversum. Paralleluniversum oder auch in dem alle irgendwie so ganz lange Arme bekommen können. Pickel Doktor. Doktor Pickel in die Notaufnahme. Wie heißt der Doktor Braun? Wie heißt der von der Schwarzwaldklinik? Ich weiß es nicht. Braun, help me. Hallo, ich bin in einer Gurke. Auf Deutsch muss ich es auch gar nicht. Ich bin in einer Gurke. Gurkenbraun. I'm Gurkenbraun. Und einfach um neue Zielgruppen abzugreifen. Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sowas passiert. Aber eigentlich geil, dass unser, ich meine, Armene Pickel war ja so das erste Podcast-UFO-Gag. Ja? So quasi. In Folge 36. Ja, genau. War so der erste richtige Podcast-Ufo-Gag. Und der ist
jetzt mittlerweile so popkulturell
durchgestattet, wie man es nie
gedacht hätte. Ja, absolut. Und Podcast-Ufo-Fans
saßen vor dem Flimmerkasten
und sagten, kann ich schon. Got it.
Got it, habe ich schon verstanden.
Habe ich schon gesehen die Folge. Die habe ich schon alles
erlebt, alles schon passiert.
Waren so gelangweilt. Ja.
Auf dem Handy geguckt, am Boden geguckt. Ich war am Wochenende zum dritten Mal in Tenet. Oh Gott. Und, hast du ihn verstanden? Nee, es ist die Dunning-Krüger-Kurve tatsächlich. Beim ersten Mal dachte ich, ich habe alles verstanden. Beim zweiten Mal genauer hingucken, ich habe doch gar nichts verstanden. Jetzt beim dritten Mal ist es, ah ja, okay, jetzt habe ich es einigermaßen verstanden. Beim vierten Mal gucken ist, glaube ich, ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Vor allem, ich denke mir so, bei der ersten Sichtung Tenet noch irgendwie ganz normales Kinopublikum, irgendwie Dates oder so, alle haben Spaß, Popcorn. Beim zweiten Mal weniger verbitterte Gesichter, viel Verwirrung, Scham auch so. Ich gucke mir noch mal. Und noch ein paar, die zum ersten Mal gucken. Ja genau, beim dritten Mal nur noch wirklich Leute, die irgendwie so eine Checkliste haben, die so ein Notizbuch haben, die so eine Flipchart, die sich aufgebaut haben und die wirklich nur noch für sich, ja aber das kann doch nicht sein, rückwärts geläufig, aber wenn es invertiert ist, alle murmeln so vor sich hin. Und dadurch versteht man wieder gar nichts. Und noch so ein Date in der Mitte des Raums, die so ein bisschen unangenehm berührt sind. Aber es ist für mich, was lächerlich war, teilweise wie einen neuen Film gucken. Ja? Weil ich habe die Sätze zum ersten Mal gehört, die unglaublich wichtig sind. Du sitzt dich auch ganz neben den Lautsprecher auch einfach und hörst ganz genau hin, was... Da war jetzt irgendwie noch eine Plotline drin. Und sie müssen ...
Aber so der wichtigste Finalkampf, ne, wo die am Ende da den Algorithmus rausballern sollen, rausholen sollen, ne?
Ja.
Ich habe, ich dachte, ich hätte es verstanden, nichts davon habe ich verstanden.
Jetzt habe ich zum ersten Mal gecheckt, was da at stake ist und immer eine Frage, dieses Armband, was der hat,
der Bösewicht, der Antagonist,
ne, dieses Fitnessarmband,
was, wenn er stirbt, was macht?
Ich dachte immer,
dann explodiert das.
Nein, das liegt ein Standort
von dem Ort,
wo der Algorithmus vergraben ist.
Das habe ich in meinem Leben noch nicht gehört.
Und es ist doch super wichtig,
worum es im Finalkampf geht. Und ich finde, das kann man
den Film dann wirklich angreifen, so gut ich ihn auch finde.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. wo der Algorithmus vergraben ist. Das habe ich in meinem Leben noch nicht gehört. Und es ist doch super wichtig, worum es im Finalkampf geht.
Und ich finde, das kann man im Film dann wirklich angreifen,
so gut ich ihn auch finde, dass man, wenn man kurz mal blinzelt oder kurz Popcorn beschützt hat, nicht mehr hinterherkommt.
Ich finde, man sollte das so machen wie im Theater.
Ich weiß noch, ich war in meiner Jugendphase oft in München im Theater
und da kriegst du, da ist eine Auslage,
bevor du ins Theater gehst, von so Dina-4-Zetteln, da steht und dann kannst du die nehmen und da steht das Stück drauf, da steht drauf, was passiert, da steht einfach drauf, hier Turando, das wird passieren, wir spielen da, die ist das, die hat das Problem und so geht's aus und einfach null Spoiler. Am Ende noch Fragen? Nee, okay. Ja, so, jetzt haben wir es auch. Und du kannst einfach sagen, okay, ich gehe ins Theater und ich gucke mir das an und ich muss mich nicht um diesen dummen Plot kümmern. Und da kann ich auch viel interessantere Dinge konstatieren. Und so sollte es im Kino auch sein. Ich brauche eine Anti-Spoiler-Bewegung. Irgendwie bräuchten sie das Gegenteil von einem Spoiler. Was ist das Gegenteil von einem Spoiler? So ein Jetpack. So ein Spoiler hält dich ja unten, so ein Jetpack. So ein Jetpack, so und dann kannst du einfach in höhere Dimensionen aufsteigen, dass du diesen ganzen Plotgedöns, diesen ganzen Wikipedia-Zusammenfassungsaspekt nicht mehr brauchst. Nein! Sondern dich einfach, dann kannst du dich auf die köstliche Cinematographie einlassen und auf das Mimen-Spiel und herrlich und wie die Komponisten... Das Mimen-Spiel. Weißt du, man sagt, das ist auch ganz toll. Glaub ich, weiß ich nicht. Ja, weiß man nicht. Ich habe zu viel, meine Augen sind zu klein. Ist auch egal. Vom ganzen Stirnrunzeln sind meine Augen zu klein, um zu verstehen, was da passiert. Vor allem, ich brauche auch Next Level Untertitel. Ich brauche nicht nur Untertitel, wir haben ja mittlerweile Gesichtserkennung. Das heißt, es ist ja überhaupt kein Problem, einfach über jede Figur zum Beispiel den Namen drüber zu schreiben. Einfach über jede Figur, Name und wie sie zu der Person gehört, mit der sie gerade zusammen gehört. Einfach zu der Person, die wir als Protagonisten empfinden. Genau, zum Beispiel du hast Protagonist und dann hat er irgendwie Name drüber, Caitlin, Schwester. Bam, fertig. Ja, ich fände noch geil, wenn er so kleine, also dann weiter eingerückt, ne, also das sind so Stichpunkte drunter. Du kannst es ausklappen, du hast lauter Dreiecke, die du dann auch händisch aufklappen kannst. Schwester, Feindin, so, dieses wichtige Punkt, und dann noch so einen Punkt weiter, wo irgendwie dann so... Was führt sie im Schilde? Ja genau, so ein kleiner Steckbrief, so Hobbys, Sternzeichen, sowas. Was führt sie im Schilde? Genau, warum hat sie nicht gesagt, dass sie das Messer gesehen hat? Sowas, ah, das ist gerade der Konflikt. Das ist gerade der Grund. Und was an dieser Figur dem Helden im Wege steht, um das Ziel zu erreichen, was am Anfang geblieben wird. Genau, und das Ziel steht die ganze Zeit oben. Das Ziel steht die ganze Zeit, will, meinetwegen Welt retten. Und natürlich Name der Schauspielerin, ist klar. Bra brauchen wir auch. Unsere Synchronsprechers, falls es einen gibt. Weil der jetzt auch immer, alles daran verhindert ja, wie geil es ist, unten immer Songs stehen, der gerade läuft. Weil sobald ein Song läuft, bin ich sofort am Handy und will den Shazam. Ja, absolut. 80 Prozent des Kinobesuchs besteht aus, woher zu hören, kenne ich diese Stimme? Diese Stimme kennt man doch, ist es immer Benjamin Blümchen, ist es Benjamin Blümchen, Walter Mörs, ist es Walter Mörs, ich weiß es nicht, und so kannst du einfach ausklicken, Caitlin, aha, hier Keira Knightley, kennst du wahrscheinlich aus Fluch der Karibik, so, bam, dann hat man es drin und dann kann man den Film genießen, so all das muss wahr sein, aber selbst dann wäre es so, nee, ich kenne die die auch woanders. Und du denkst dir, ja, Flug der Karibik, geiler Film, kann ich eigentlich auch mal wieder gucken. Ja, und dann ist so der nächste genervte Unterpunkt, wollen Sie Flug der Karibik gucken? Ja, okay, hier, klicken Sie hier. Man sollte immer nur zwei Klicks von Flug der Karibik entfernt sein, egal wo im Film man ist. Sowieso. Immer. Aber bei Amazon ist es ja so, da stehen immer sämtliche Schauspieler, die gerade im Bild sind, stehen da, wenn du die Maus bewegst. Das heißt, irgendjemand... Anstrengend in so einer Massenszene. Absolut, irgendjemand musste mehr oder weniger Frame für Frame durchgehen und immer sagen, jetzt geht die ab, jetzt tritt der auf. Deswegen habe ich The Red Wedding nicht verstanden, weil da kurz als alle Schauspieler im Frame waren, plötzlich der ganze Frame voll war mit Bildern von den Schauspielern im Anzug. Und dann schlagartig erklärte sich die Namen und man denkt sich, ach, warum ist jetzt Kit Harington im Anzug? Warum ist das so ein Bild von so einem Red Carpet? Ich dachte Red Wedding. Aber sind nicht manchmal Red Carpets auch wie eine Red Wedding? Ich glaube schon. Wenn ich da an unseren Comedypreis 2016 zurückdenke, wo wir uns schmachvoll an einen Fotografen vorbeigeschlichen haben. Wie traurig war es bitte, gestern war, nee, letzte Woche Freitag war zum ersten Mal der Comedypreis und ich war nicht da seit sechs Jahren. Das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal, dass ich nicht da war, obwohl ich in der Branche arbeite. Wie gemein. Ja, du bist jetzt langsam angenehmer Künstler. Du bist ja nicht mehr der Currywurst, Stefan, der irgendwie am Comedypreis zusammen irgendwie mit Roche Gonzales sich irgendwie eine kostenlose Currywurst abholt. Nein, das bist du nicht mehr, Stefan. Du bist in Cannes unterwegs, du bist ein Mann von Klasse und Stil und du hast damit nichts zu tun. Trotzdem, herzlichen Glückwunsch von Herringedeck, ganz grossartig. Mega, viel Glück. Viel voll cool. Shoutout an Herringedeck, auch nur einen Klick entfernt. In der Spotify-App sind alle auch... Das Lebensglück ist nur einen Klick entfernt. Ausser Shining von Stephen King ist jetzt nicht mehr bei Spotify ist jetzt nicht mehr nur einen Klick entfernt. D ich. Oh, ist es kurz noch, ist aber jetzt weg. Ich fühle mich auch gerade so ein bisschen wie, das Glück ist nur einen Klick entfernt, denn im Anschluss an diese Aufnahme werde ich eine der kleinen Freuden des modernen Menschen tätigen, und zwar ein saftiger Behördengang. Behördengang gleich? Behördengang im Anschluss und zwar... Welches Amt erstmal? Das Amt, Bürgeramt. Nee, es gibt nicht das, da bist du ganz weit davon entfernt gerade. Du bist schon, du musst dich jetzt, bereiten wir dich mal besser auf den Behördengang gleich vor. Nee, nee, nee, ich hole meinen Reisepass ab. Nein! Reisepass ist fertig, habe ich beantwortet. Florentin Will Will vielleicht. Ja, vielleicht, ja, kann sein. Oder Florentin Will Tietze, verdammt nochmal. Google Autocorrect einfach, immer sofort, schreiben die da rein. Wir dachten uns, wir schreiben noch ein Failed, was uns so noch einfällt dazu. Ich hole meinen Reisepass ab, weil ich bin ein Mensch, ich bin jetzt wieder Mensch, ich darf wieder Mensch sein. Man muss sagen, du warst eine Person, die noch gerade hat. Ich war lange off the grid, ich war ein Parier, ein gesellschaftlicher und er war als Stars. Ja, so jemand, der abseits der Gesellschaft liegt. Wie heißt das Wort? Paria, glaube ich. Ich werde auch gern, bei dir hätte ich auch immer Untertitel. Und zwar, ich war eine Persona non grata, ich war ausgeschlossen und ich habe mir irgendwann gesagt, das geht so nicht weiter. Und ich wollte den Reisepass und den Reisepass auch schon abgelaufen und dann meinte der bei der Behörde so, der ist jetzt schon seit sechs Monaten abgelaufen und ich so, ja gut, jetzt Reisen ist jetzt eh schlecht und so.
Oh, die beste Zeit ist erwischt, die beste Zeit, nein, nein, nein. Und dann meinte er so, ja, dann brauche ich einen Personalausweis und dann ich so, der ist aber auch schon seit einer Weile abgelaufen und eben schon mit so einem und jenen Blick und ich gebe ihm den Personalausweis abgelaufen 2013 und er meinte jetzt so der ist jetzt schon seit sieben jahren abgelaufen ich so ja ich meine seit wann gibt es corona 2014 wie man am anfang des gesprächs obwohl es ja zu dem Punkt eh kommen wird, dass es ihn gibt, ist ja unausweichlich, dass du irgendwann diesen 2013 abgelaufenen Pass rüber schiebst. Ja, wo ich mit fettigen langen Locken als 16-jähriger Florentin will, noch wirklich sämtlich keine einzige gute Entscheidung getroffen in seinem Leben bis zu diesem Punkt. Und obwohl dieser Punkt ja irgendwann kommt, sagt man am Anfang, moderiert man es ja nicht an mit, der ist schon ewig abgelaufen, moderiert es an mit der ist vor kurzem abgelaufen. Also warum? Man weiß auch nicht, was für Verhältnisse existieren. Man investiert in bessere nächste zwei Minuten, dafür dass aber die danach vollen Minuten schlimmer sind. Absolut, man baut sich die Brücke Stück für Stück vor sich und weiß nicht, wohin sie führt. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, wollen Sie auch direkt einen neuen Personalausweis?
Und das war, glaube ich, der schönste Satz, den ich seit langem, langem gehört habe, weil ich gesagt habe, ja, und dann bin ich wieder frei.
Boah, welcher Basis kriegst du denn jetzt, weil du hast kein amtliches Ausweisdokument mehr gehabt?
Nein, nein, aber ich habe gesagt, gucken Sie mal in mein Gesicht, das ist mein Ausweis.
Lach ich?
Sie kennen mich.
Ach so, Flontin Will, Rocket Beans TV,
Sujo TV,
die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von?
Ne.
Sagt ihn gar nichts? Rapide, rapante Podcast?
Ah, ne.
Nein? Überhaupt nicht?
Aber Podcasts höre ich gerade gern.
Gemüschtes Hack, finde ich toll.
Ach so. Ja, ich habe Felix Lobrecht
mal auf der Straße gesehen, der ist mir mal entgegengekommen. Haben Sie sonst einen Führerschein wenigstens? Ich habe einen Lego-Führerschein aus dem Legoland Günzburg, aber das ist es. Und was hast du dann abgegeben? Abgegeben und dann hat er auch gesagt, soll ich den vernichten oder wollen Sie ihn als Erinnerungsstück? Und ich dachte mir, er sei einmal erwachsen und sage, vernichten Sie ihn. Aber ich habe gesagt, nein, ich will das als Erinnerungsstück. Weil so bescheuert wie auf diesem alten Personalausweis mit 16, sehe ich sonst nirgendwo aus wirklich. Es ist ein grandioses Foto, deswegen habe ich gesagt. Und dann kam ein sehr interessanter Moment, und zwar heißt es, ah, hier steht, da waren Sie 16, ne, bei dem Personalausweis, ja. Ja, hier steht 1,77. Ist das denn noch aktuell? Da denkst du dir so, ich werde doch gewachsen sein. Ja, aber du kennst deine Grösse nicht? Ja, ich kenne meine Grösse nicht, aber ja, war so immer so drei. Zwanzig. Also auch so, und er dann so, ja, sie können sich da hinten messen gott da muss er den ganzen raum gehen und war er wieder in zettel ziehen diese schlange weil dieser raum ist ja riesig mit ganz vielen schaltern und säulen und er deutet nur so grob in die himmelsrichtung an da hinten können sie sich messen und ich stehe auf und locker drei minuten irre ich durch diesen raum immer wieder blick zurück zu ihm der wartet, keinerlei Hilfe gibt und ich gucke mich um, irgendwann habe ich dann dieses scheiß Maßband gefunden, mess mich, 1,78. Ich bin ein Zentimeter gewachsen, vielleicht sind es meine Schuhe, ein Zentimeter gewachsen, seit ich 16 Jahre alt bin. Mit Schuhen gemessen? Natürlich sind es dann deine Schuhe. Nee, das Maßband war so ein bisschen höher als der Rest, ganz komisch auch auf jeden Fall. Und dann dachte ich mir so, naja, das weiss der jetzt aber nicht, was ich gemessen habe. Nee, und 1,77 ist ja auch die schönere Zahl. Moment, du willst doch mehr draufpacken? Auf dem Weg, ich sag mal so, Ausweisdokumente sind dafür, dass sie sich ausweisen, nicht dass sie einen anderen Menschen ausweisen.
Ja, aber Stefan, wir alle wissen doch, dass man manche Tage hat, wo man einfach jedes bisschen Selbstbewusstsein braucht, das man kriegen kann.
Jedes Lächeln vom Bäcker braucht man einfach.
Die lachen dich aus, die lachen dich aus, du bist nicht zwei Meter dreizehn groß.
Es gibt Tage, da kann man auf sowas verzichten, aber andere Tage, da braucht man alles, was man kriegen kann.
Und auch wenn wir die Die lachen dich aus, du bist nicht zwei Meter dreizehn groß. Es gibt Tage, da kann man auf sowas verzichten, ja, aber andere Tage, da braucht man alles, was man kriegen kann. Und auf dem Weg vom Maßband zurück zum Schalter war wirklich so ein Satan auf der einen Schulter, Hazel Brugger auf der anderen Schulter, die um meine Seele gerungen haben. Und ich dachte mir so, ach komm, da noch einen Zentimeter drauf, machst du die 1,80 voll, das klingt gut, das ist für viele auf Tinder so eine Grenze. Du hast die 1,80 voll gemacht? Und dann sagt Hazel Brugge, aber nein, du kannst doch jetzt nicht zwei Zentimeter oben drauf machen, weißt du was das heißt, die guten Menschen auf Tinder, das kannst du doch nicht machen, das bist du doch nicht, so habe ich dich nicht kennengelernt damals, als ich beim Podcast UFO zu Gast war.
Und Satan sagt wieder, nein, nutz die Gelegenheit, scheiss doch auf die anderen.
Warum ist Hazel Brugger in diese Fantasywelt reingerutscht?
Für mich ist Hazel Brugger die Inkarnation von Gutgütigkeit.
Und dann komme ich an, der Vertrag liegt vor mir, mein Finger blutet, bin ich bereit, meine Seele zu verkaufen? Und er fragt nur und, und ich sage, 1,79. Ich habe einen Zentimeter draufgepackt. Oh mein Gott. Einen Zentimeter oben draufgepackt. Oh mein Gott. Ja, ich glaube das jetzt nicht. Man hat gefragt, und ihre Augenfarbe hat sich ja auch verändert. Und da hinten ist ein Spiegel. Da hinten rechts ist ein großer Spiegel. Aber auch so zwei kleine ovale Spiegel. Ganz kleine Spiegel. Wo man nur die Augen sehen kann. Und wenn du dich vorher gemessen hast, dann weißt du, zu welchem Spiegel du gehen musst. Du gehst zu dem, weil du 1,79 eingeben hast, gehst du zu dem Spiegel, der leicht zu hoch ist. Ja genau, oh stimmt, und dann fliegt es auf. Und da fliegt es dann auf. Und ich habe jetzt tatsächlich Grössenbetrug begangen. Okay. Wobei man sagen muss, dass dieses Maßband auch ziemlich schwammig war und man kann sich ja schlecht messen, wenn man nicht irgendwie so ein Was-is-was-Buch hat, das man sich auf den Kopf legen kann. Richtig. Sondern man muss so mit Augenmaßen und wahrscheinlich habe ich da eh zwei, drei Zentimeter, wahrscheinlich bin ich eh viel grösser.
Ja, genau. Zehn Haare zu Körpergrösse, verstehe ich immer auch nicht.
Weil hier immer so eine Turmfrisur. Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Und meine Löckchen, die sind ja tiefer. Aber meine Turmfrisur
hat mich immer gross gemacht. Jetzt bin ich nur noch 1,78 groß.
Obwohl, es gibt ja diesen Simpsons-Gag, wo sie die Kinder messen und dann haben alle so eine Linie und Bart hat halt so eine gezackte Linie. Aber da müsste man sagen, da wurde natürlich von den Haaren gemessen. Aber Lisa hat doch auch gezackte Haare. Die Simpsons sind auch nicht mehr das, was sie immer war. So eine Scheisse. Ja, das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass wenn ich heute zur Behörde gehe, da durchaus die Polizei auf mich wartet und bereit ist, mich auf sich zu erschießen. Und ich bin bereit zu gehen. Ich hatte eine schöne Zeit auf dieser Erde. Seit ich 16 bin, habe ich dann noch die eine oder andere richtige Entscheidung getroffen. Und ja, spannend. Aber nochmal zurück zu dem Punkt, den du dann so leicht übersprungen hast plötzlich. Wie hast du es geschafft, dich auszuweisen für die Neubeantragung eines Personalausweises oder Reisepasses ohne gültigem Ausweisdokument? Naja, ich hatte ja meinen alten Pass und da steht ja drin, ah, das bist du so. Also, das ist ja klar, dass ich das bin. Das weiss ich nicht. Naja, ich glaube, es ist einfacher für die Behörde zu sagen, ja, passt schon, als zu sagen, ja, sie müssen jetzt nochmal ganz von vorne anfangen. Sie brauchen eine Geburtsurkunde, sie brauchen eine Grundschulausbildung, sie fangen jetzt nochmal bei Null an. Und hier machen sie sich nochmal das Seepferdchen, da ist das Ossendorf-Bade, da können sie jetzt hingehen. Ja, Seepferdchen, sie brauchen noch mal irgendwie die Milchzähne, alles muss noch mal von vorne. Nicht die Zahnspange, doch die doch, doch die gibt's auch. Nein, und dann einfach noch mal von vorne, glaube ich, das ist halt ein bisschen viel Aufwand. Voll, deswegen lass es nicht beides ablaufen. Immer eins, es ist wie so, wenn man Roller fährt. Das ist so wie Bett und Stuhl, auf einem ist immer der Kleiderhaufen, aber der andere ist frei. Aber du wählst deine Probleme immer nur von zwei Punkten hin und her. Das ist okay, solange eins frei ist. Fängt nicht an, auf den Stuhl auch noch Kleiderhaufen zu labern. Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Und denkt nicht, oh, das ist eine Hose, die zieht später noch mal an und dann macht man einen separaten Teil des Haufen aus. Du wurdest faul. Ich habe zumindest jetzt noch einen gültigen, bis glaube ich 2022 gültigen Reisepass.
Mein Ausweis ist schon lange abgelaufen.
Aber du brauchst auch nicht zwei Sachen, das verstehe ich auch immer nicht.
Nee, vor allem, ich habe ja wirklich seit 2013 abgelaufen ein Passwort und das interessiert niemanden.
Niemanden.
Ich komme mit meinem Lego-Führerschein wirklich überall durch.
Damit bin ich in 300 gekommen.
Du bist mit deinem Lego-Führerschein wirklich überall durch. Damit bin ich in 300 gekommen. Du bist mit deinem Lego-Führerschein in 300 gekommen. Ja, ich bin... Lego 300. Warum gibt es nicht so Lego Saw? Stimmt eigentlich. Lego Blair Witch Project. Und wenn jemand blutet, dann kommen so diese kleinen roten Kreise. Genau, diese Kreisnöppel raus. Diese Kreisnübel, die man da draußen hat.
Eigentlich sollte es jeden Film nochmal als Lego geben.
Ich finde vor allem so Kevin in the Woods oder halt so
Saw. Ja.
Final Destination, aber als Lego.
Ja, Martyr ist einfach nochmal Lego.
Einfach nochmal die härtesten Filme der Welt.
Ja.
Nochmal als Lego. Fände ich eigentlich witzig.
Richtig gut.
Lars von Trier Filme würde ich auch gerne
Lego sehen.
Melancholia Lego. Melancholia Lego. Werbung. Ich bin ja immer wieder am Bahnhofskiosk unterwegs und ich liebe nichts mehr, als sich da die ganzen Magazine anzugucken, irgendwie mal reinzublättern in so verschiedene Magazine. Aber im Endeffekt ist es dann doch immer zu überwältigen. Ich kaufe mir am Ende doch keine, weil du nicht weißt, welche soll man kaufen. Ja und die sind auch teuer. Ja, die sind richtig teuer und deswegen habe ich aufgegeben, Magazine zu lesen. Bis jetzt, denn wir haben was für euch, Readly. Bei Readly könnt ihr für einen Festpreis im Monat, 9,99 Euro, fast alle Magazine auf der ganzen Welt lesen. Die haben 5000 Magazine im Angebot, die könnt ihr alle lesen für diesen Festpreis, wie ein Streamer, könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie Netflix. Fantastische Magazine sind mit dabei, für uns natürlich ganz besonders Wissenschaftsmagazine, Sterne und Weltraum ist dabei, National Geographic, Men's Health natürlich, Kochen und Genießen, Psychologie heute, also für alles was dabei. Und das Tolle ist ja, du kannst ja wirklich komplett in hunderte verschiedene Magazine mal reinlesen. Rein stöbern. Du musst dich nicht festlegen, weil du zahlst nur einen Festpreis und es gibt keinerlei Exklusivkosten für bestimmte Magazine oder so. Da sind wirklich alle mit dabei. Und das Beste ist, wenn ihr auf readly.com slash podcastufo geht, haben wir das Schmankerl für euch, ihr bekommt Readly zwei Monate lang für nur 1,99 Euro. Und auf der Seite haben wir noch ein paar exklusive Magazin-Empfehlungen vorbereitet. Ihr könnt alle Magazine ganz bequem in der App lesen, somit auch natürlich unterwegs, immer zugänglich und jederzeit griffbereit. Keine Abo-Falle, jederzeit kündbar. Readly. Werbung Im Ernst? Dein Lego-Führerschein hat wirklich geholfen? Ja, ja klar. Ich war damals, der Film, ich glaube, 300 ist ab 16 und ich war halt 16 und musste mich ausweisen, dass ich alt genug bin, um in den Film zu kommen. Und da hatte ich noch keinen Ausweis und dann habe ich das gemeinsam gemacht. Ironischerweise, dass ein Lego-Führerschein einem anderen beweis, dass man alt genug ist für etwas, ist auch ein bisschen weird. Aber erklär mir ganz kurz, wie man zu einem Lego-Führersin kommt. Naja, man ist in Legoland Günzburg unterwegs und es sagt... Sagst du das Wort immer so der Stadt oder heißt es wirklich Legoland Günzburg? Du musst ja wissen, welches Legoland. Es gibt ja verschiedene Legoländer. Ich kenne Billund. Genau, nicht in Billund, da war ich auch schon, aber ich rede jetzt von Legoland Günzburg. Und dann sagst du, ja, es ist an der Zeit, ich wohne auf dem Land, ich brauche mehr Mobilität, ich will auch mal, sage ich mal, ein fesches Mädel mit zum Volksfest nehmen, ich brauche jetzt ein Auto, der Schritt ist gekommen. Und dann sagst du, ja, ich brauche jetzt einen Führerschein im Legoland, mache ich jetzt einen Führerschein und dann fährst du halt in diesen Lego-Autos da rum, in diesen kleinen Autos. Aber in diesen Festen mit der Sch auch, ne? Nein, nein, nein, da darf schon gelenkt werden, da wird schon gelenkt. Da wird Autoscooter. Nein, es gibt schon so vorgefertigte Strassen, also es ist schon ein Strassensystem, es ist keine Rennstrecke, es ist wie eine Stadt, wo es auch Ampeln gibt und so, so Lego City, glaube ich. Und so Kinder, die da arbeiten. Kinder, die da arbeiten müssen. Kinder, die ein Auto waschen. Die die Fensterscheibe putzen. Und so manche, die jonglieren, vor allem an Ampeln jonglieren, weil sie noch Kleingeld brauchen. Dann gibst du denen so Lego-Geld. Es ist, ja, es ist... Es hat sich ein bisschen verselbstständigt, muss man sagen. Und man darf halt auch nicht in die düsteren Ecken dieser Lego-Stadt fahren, wo durchaus jemand mit so einem Legomesser dir durchaus dein Legogeld abknüpfen kann. Aber gut, da wird man davor gewahrt. Es ist völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufen. Nochmal, sorry an die Eltern, tut uns total leid, aber das ist irgendwie, wir wollten diese kleine Legostadt machen, das war irgendwie so eine süße Idee, aber es ist leider völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufen. Der Sohn ist jetzt leider Anführer einer recht gewalttätigen Bande, die leider die komplette Ostküste beherrscht. Des Legolandes? Oh nein. Die Policeforst, die Hubschrauber trauen sich leider nicht mehr in dieses Gebiet und ja, es tut mir leid. Die Lego-Hubschrauber trauen sich nicht mehr ins Gebiet. Können wir mit einer echten Polizei versuchen, das wieder in den Griff zu bekommen? Die echte Polizei hat hier keine Macht. Wie? Die echte Polizei hat hier keine Macht. Niemand. Und dann machst du halt deine Führerscheinprüfung und dann kriegst du den Führerschein, dann machst du ein Foto und dann hast du den Lego-Führerschein. Das heißt, ich bin berechtigt, Lego-Fahrzeuge zu führen. Pkw. Lego-Pkw. Lego-Pkw. Aber einen Legoroller müsste es ja nochmal einen eigenen Führer. Roller nicht. Roller nicht, Motorrad auch nicht. Bkw bin ich imstande, habe ich einen Führerschein gemacht und natürlich ein Foto gemacht. Foto ist da drauf und das ist der einzige Lichtbildausweis, den ich besitze. Hättest du dir zum Zeitpunkt gedacht, dass das nochmal so wichtig ist, der dieser Lego-Führersche? Ehrt gesagt nicht. Also natürlich die erste Woche, nachdem ich ihn gemacht habe, dachte ich mir, ich bin ein neuer Mensch, ich bin mobil. Und mir ist dann aber aufgefallen, dass außerhalb des Legoland Günzburgs es gar nicht so viele von diesen Lego-Autos gibt, die ich dann hätte führen können. Also das war dann doch relativ beschränkt auf Legoland Günzburg, in dem ich ein einziges Mal in meinem Leben war. Sollte ich jemals zurückkehren, kann ich direkt einsteigen, ohne den Test machen zu müssen. Ich habe jetzt drei Wochen frei, tatsächlich. Ich habe Urlaub, Urlaub Stefan, und ich habe tatsächlich auch überlegt, schon mal in den Freizeitpark zu gehen. Ja. Ich glaube, also irgendwie denke ich mir, ist es der Wunsch eines Zwölfjährigen gerade in mir, aber vielleicht auch ja, warum auch nicht mal einfach solche Sachen mal wieder machen. Ich habe so Lust auf Freizeitpark, weil die leer sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich, sollte man vielleicht auch nicht hingehen, einfach gerade weil es aus einem Grund leer ist. Ja, aber es ist leer, schon ein leerer Freizeitpark. Gute Gründe, gute Gründe. Also Hezelbrugger sagt mir, gehen die mal nicht hin, aber Satan wiederum sagt Kristall. Ja, okay. Sagt, geh hin, geh hin. Geh hin, ist es leer. Du musst selber entscheiden, Legoland-Günsburg, kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Da gibt es auch so einen grossen Haikopf, Haifischkopf aus Lego, der den Mund aufreißt. Du musst auch nicht mal sagen, aus Lego, wenn du über das Legoland-Günsburg sprichst. Du musst nicht immer sagen, da gibt es ein aus Lego. Wie sind dieses Suffix kannst du dir sparen? Gut, also da gibt es einen grossen Haifischkopf, der das Maul aufreißt, wo du deinen Kopf durchstecken kannst, von hinten. Dann sieht es für einen kurzen Moment, für einen unbedarften Betrachter, für eine Sekunde so aus. Dritten, für einen unbeteiligten Dritten, für einen Moment so aus, als würdest du in dem Gebiss des Haies feststecken. Und nach dieser kurzen Streiksekunde löst sich die Illusion recht schnell auf, dass das nicht der Fall ist, sondern nur ein Lego, ein Haifischkopf aus Klemmbausteinen, dem du deinen Kopf durchgesteckt. Aber das sind Dinge, die kannst du nur... Klemmbausteine klingt ja fantastisch. Das ist der offiziell übergeordnete Begriff für diese Art von Steine, ja. Für Legosteine. Es gibt ja auch andere, es gibt ja auch noch Kobi und andere. Kobi ist wie Bing. Kobi ist ein bisschen wie Bing, ja. Wer hält da noch die Stange oder das Ruder? Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich bin jache ja da manchmal rein. Bei Kubi rutschst du rein? Nein, nein, generell in die Klembau-Lyrik. Da stolper ich manchmal rein in diese Welt und natürlich großer Fan vom Held der Steine. Und das sind wirklich so Deep Dives. Der war auch da bei diesem Lego-Masters, wo ich zu viel reingeguckt habe, wo die eine Messie bekommen haben. Nicht mal aus Lego, sondern echt eine Messie. Nein, mir fucking gerecht. Was soll ich damit anfangen? Was soll ich denn da tun? Das krieg ich doch nicht in meine halbrunde Hand reingeklemmt. Sind da wenigstens so Sticker drin, die ich auf meine Legosteine kleben kann? Nein! Oh, das ist ein gefährliches Thema. Sticker, ne? Ja, Sticker mag er gar nicht. Mag ich auch immer nicht. Ja, die sind doof. Da wird es dann irgendwie auch so kindlich. Wenn man dann so ein Lego-ATS, die bauen, ist geil, aber wenn dann diese Sticker kommen, denkt man, ich bin keine zwölf mehr. Auf der Packung steht elf bis vierzehn, okay? Also das sind durchausössere Kinder gemeint. Aber Freizeitpark hätte ich wieder Bock drauf. Schöne wilde Maus, mal so ein riesiger Rollator. Ich glaube, die wilde Maus-Achterbahn könnte ich aus dem Kopf die Schienen aufmalen. Ist immer die gleiche. Die wilde Maus-Achterbahn ist ein Hersteller und der baut immer das gleiche Schienensystem, das gleiche Streckensystem. Die Wilde Maus, die er auch der Kirmes kennt, ist die gleiche, die er auch im Zentrum Oberhausen findet, ist die... So wie all die, die auch immer gleich aussehen. Sind die immer gleich aus? Für jeden Gang gleich? Es gibt auch manche, die sind anders aus. Nö, aber du gehst immer rein und dann rechts und dann hast du erstmal den Kaffee und die Milchbrötchen und dann geht's
weiter zum Backautomat, dann hast du die Süßigkeiten, dann Wein und so. Aber es gibt manche, die sind dann Gebäuden angepasst, die dann so ein bisschen verwinkelter sind und so. Ja, ich glaube, wenn du das Gebäude extra für den Aldi baust, dann wahrscheinlich gleich. Gut, das wäre so. Haben wir uns getroffen. Aber wilde Maus war mir tatsächlich, auch wenn es natürlich dynamisch schon impliziert zu mausig zu viel maus wäre es der wilde Maus war mir tatsächlich, auch wenn es natürlich dynamisch schon impliziert, zu viel Maus. Zu viel Maus. Wärst du der wilde Hund, wäre ich sofort dabei. Aber zu Mäusen kann ich keine emotionale Bindung aufbauen. Ich bräuchte da so eine Light-Variante, so eine milde Maus oder sowas, wo man irgendwie so locker einsteigt und man sagt, so für Anfänger. Du Lego, du bist immer noch im Lego mit deinen Gedanken.
Lass von dem Legoland mal.
Du willst die Lego-Version von der wilden Maus.
Das ist jetzt ein Klischee, mit dem ich aufräumen möchte, dass es im Legoland Günzburg es nur irgendwie so Kinderachterbahnen gäbe.
Nein, da gibt es knallharte Achterbahnen, die wirklich mithalten können mit einem Europapark-Rust.
Was?
Mit einem Euro-Mart. Ja, das hast du schon gesagt. Mit einem Europapark-Rust überall, also die kann mithalten. Also das lasse ich mir nicht gefallen, dass du mit so einem altbackenen Vorurteil hier um die Ohren haust. Aber da gibt es eine richtige Achterbahn. Ja, da gibt es eine Wildwasserbahn, das Wasser ist aus blauem Legostein. Aber warum ist immer alles aus fucking Lego? Und vor allem, wer hat entschieden, im Ernst, das ist eine ernste Frage, was nicht aus Lego ist im Legoland. Da sind ein paar Sachen nicht aus Lego. Zum Beispiel würde ich mal behaupten, die Fritteuse im Pommesbodenstand ist nicht aus Lego. Verstehe ich, das ist okay. Wahrscheinlich so ein Vernünftiger, der irgendwie der Spielverderber ist. Wie wäre es denn, wenn so die Sicherheitsbügel bei den Achterbahnen, wenn die auch aus Lego wären, ja geil, mega geil, dann können wir so einen Schatten machen, die sind so silber und dann einer so, sorry, ganz kurz. Das ... Der Erwachsene. Das waren der Erwachsene im Raum. Alles waren so Kinder.
Die anderen sitzen so am Boden auf so einer Matte mit ganz vielen Legosteinen um sich
und planen den Park.
Und der Erwachsene im Atem.
Die planen den Park auf so einem Teppich mit so Strassen. Genau, ja, und jeder hat schon so seine eigenen Klötze gebaut. Bunt, komplett bunt. Und überall stehen diese bunten Plastikbecher mit Apfelsaft. In der Mitte so ein Stahlstang. Und ein Erwachsener sitzt am Rand auf dem Stuhl, der einzige, und er ab und zu so sagt, nee.
Nee, entschuldigung, versicherungsrechtlich Sicherheit ist es absolut. Und Tim, jetzt gib ihm mal die Salzstangen wieder. Auch mal von den blauen Steinen für Lisa bitte da. Du nimmst ihm immer alle blauen Steine raus. So, und jetzt weiter. Und die Kinder dann wieder so. Und da habe ich mir im Eingangsbereich gedacht. Also vor allem, es ist ja tatsächlich so, ich war ja absolut geflasht, wenn du da essen gehst, natürlich bestellst du die Pommes und die Pommes sind in Form eines Sterns. Was? Wie? Nein, natürlich eines Legosteins, eines Legosteins, den man aber nicht bauen kann, was ich sehr schade fand. Meine erste Intuition war als Kind natürlich, ich will mit meinen Pommes bauen, geht aber nicht. Man gibt es den Pommes, das Pommes-Legoland, dann wird es wire. Danke, sag mal, oh Gott, dann muss ich den Pommes-Legoland-Führerschein machen. Leute, wie wäre es, wenn die Komite achtet waren, auf Pommes ist es ... So, jetzt reicht's! Jetzt reicht's! Ihr geht jetzt ins Bett, es ist auch schon spät. Und da war ich auf jeden Fall frustriert, dass man die mit Pommes nicht bauen konnte. Das weiß ich noch, ich erinnere mich noch an das konkrete Gefühl. An das konkrete Gefühl. An den Geruch von dem Moment, wo ich das Gefühl hatte. Der Enttäuschung dieser Pommes, an der, okay, dann baue ich die aus Pommes, nein, geht nicht. Aber dann war das Gefühl sehr schnell wieder gut, weil die Pommes sehr lecker waren.
Genau, ich habe die Pommes gegessen. Auch wenn eine Lego-Steinform nicht ideal ist für eine Pommes, weil du hast einen ziemlich massiven Körper und die sechs Nöppel obendrauf, die dann ein bisschen knuspriger sind, aber naja. Ja, aber krass, also die haben es irgendwie geschafft. Ich finde, ist auch geil. Auch wie Christoph Niemann in der Doku bei ihm, der Grafiker, Designer, wie er dann anfängt mit Lego so kleine, zum Beispiel die Staten Island Ferry nachbaut und sowas. Das hat auch so, das ist total geil, was auch für einen Designaspekt dahintersteckt, dieses minimalistische, diese Abstraktion von echten Gegenständen und so. Darauf hätte ich ja meistens Bock. Ich habe gar nicht so Bock auf so Lego-Sets, sondern eher auf ... Selber was nachbauen.
Ich will hundert von diesen ...
Orangen. von echten Gegenständen und so. Darauf hätte ich ja meistens Bock, ich habe gar nicht so Bock auf so Lego-Sets, sondern eher auf selber was nachbauen. Ich will hundert von diesen orangenen, flachen Zweierplättchen und damit dann versuchen, alles zu bauen. Und dann hundert blaue, hundert gelbe, hundert rote, so das fände ich cool und dann kannst du so Sachen bauen. Ich glaube, du brauchst viel mehr. Ich will einfach graue Steine, graue Steine und zwar diese drei mal zwei Dinger von oben. Drei mal zwei? Also diese sechs, diese sechser, diese klassischen. Ja, das kriege ich auch noch hin, ja, aber danke. Wo ist die sechsunddreißig? Die Steine, weißt du, und die ein bisschen dicker sind, diese klassischen Ziegelsteine. Von denen hätte ich gerne dreitausend und dann würde ich damit
mal anfangen rumzubauen.
Weil ich glaube, da kriegst du alles einiges.
Nicht die viermal zweier.
Verbaut man sich mit dreimal zweier nicht total viel,
weil du die nicht...
Aber gut, von mir aus. Nicht, dass du
dann Mitte der Hälfte bei deiner Golden
Gate Bridge merkst, das war eine
unglaublich dumme Idee. Meine
Lieblingssteine wären die flachen
einmal zweier.
Einmal zwei? Du bist komplett
Vielen Dank. Und bei Gatebridge merkst du, das war eine unglaublich dumme Idee. Meine Lieblingssteine wären die flachen Einmalzweier.
Einmalzweier? Du bist komplett flach durchgeknallt? Die flachen aber.
Was ist passiert in der letzten Zeit mit dir? Warum?
Das ist der schlechteste Stein.
Das ist der beste Stein.
Das ist wie die kleine Version von meinem Stein, du brauchst einfach nur länger.
Nein, aber du kannst viel filigranere Formen bauen.
Und Einmalzweier ist die perfekte Art, weil du kannst alles kombinieren, du kannst daraus jede andere Form bauen, du kannst hoch, seitlich bauen, flach. Meine sind nur grössere Versionen von diesem Stein. Meine Abschritte ist groß. Du willst jetzt, dass wir uns beim Lego Day anmelden und jeder kriegt eine Wagenladung von seinem Lieblingsstein und dann guck mal, wer was Besseres baut. Garantiert dir das nicht, was Cooleres baut als du? Das ist nicht auch ein bisschen blöd mit dem ganzen Plastik, was da entsteht?
Es gibt aber,
es gab mal
so kompostierbare
Legoschne, die irgendwie nachhaltig waren, und zwar
in Form von Pflanzen. Das fand ich
genial. Könntest du dann so eine Legobox
kaufen mit Legopflanzen,
die aus einem Material
sind, das irgendwie dann wieder recycelt werden kann.
Oder aus Pflanzen gemacht wird. Ich glaube, es wurde aus Pflanzen gemacht. Es kann nicht wieder recycelt werden, aber es wurde zumindest Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das irgendwie dann wieder recycelt werden kann oder aus Pflanzen gemacht wird.
Ich glaube, es wurde aus Pflanzen gemacht, es kann nicht wieder recycelt werden, aber es wurde zumindest nicht aus Öl gemacht, sondern aus einer schönen Mohnblume oder sowas wurde das dann gemacht. Mohnblume? Aber warum das nicht aus, ich glaube, irgendwann ist es auch für alle Steine, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Ja, ne ist ist schön. Ich habe richtig Bock jetzt auf Freizeitpark, aber so ein richtiges, mit richtigen Achterbahnen. Das Phantasialand ist, glaube ich, auch dort. Übrigens aber, vielleicht ist die Wilde Maus Achterbahn im Hansapark in Sirksdorf was für dich, weil die heißt Crazy Mine. Und da geht es um eine, das hat ein Minenthema und so ein bisschen Wild West, du fährst mit einem Minenwagen durch so ein Grand Canyon-artiges Ding.
Ach so, wie Goldmine.
Toll, ganz toll.
Und das ist genau die gleiche Achterbahn, halt nur für dich in einem anderen Gewand, vielleicht weg von der Maus, vielleicht ein bisschen spannender.
Okay.
Aber auch genau das gleiche Streckensystem, genau wie die, die manchmal hier in Deutz, in Köln am Rhein steht, wenn da Kirmes ist.
Schön, gleiches Design, nur da ist die Fest und in so einem Minenthema. Was wir noch nicht verstanden haben, war Geisterbaden. Ich erinnere mich noch einmal, dass ich mit meinem Vater auf dem Oktoberfest war und wir bestimmt eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde gewartet haben. Ist das Oktoberfest nicht eine große Geisterbahn? Ne, da gibt es ja verschiedene Geisterbahnen, also ein paar gibt es da schon auch drauf.
Und da musste man dann wirklich richtig lange warten, ich war wirklich klein, irgendwie so acht Jahre alt oder sowas, noch jünger, und dann haben wir eine Stunde gewartet bis zur Geisterbahn, setzen uns in den Wagen und ich mache die gesamte Fahrt der Geisterbahn, kneife ich die Augen zu und halte mir mit den Händen die Ohren zu. Und dann fahr da auch so, warum haben wir uns da jetzt acht Stunden für angestellt? Wir fahren da durch und ich wirklich schaue auf den Boden, kneife alles zu wenig. Und kommst raus und sagst, das war super, nochmal. Und fahr raus und dann einfach, gut, das war's, jetzt holen wir uns eine Brezel. Bist du so ein klassischer Bayer im Sinne von, dust gerne Bresel und Weichwurst? Das ist ja meine eigene Heimat. Naja, wobei, wir waren, als wir nach New York geflogen sind, wir beiden, da haben wir uns tatsächlich am Frankfurter Flughafen erstmal schön nochmal von Bresel und Weichwurst ernährt, weiß ich noch. Das stimmt, das muss auch schon sein, wenn man mal von Frankfurt nach New York fliegt, dann darf auch mal Barbaria ein bisschen durchschimmern. Das finde ich auch gut, das gibt es ja auch in Amerika und gibt es auch zum Beispiel am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof gibt es auch so ein bayerisches Ding, wo man dann auch so bayerische Sachen kaufen kann, das scheint, wo man dich oft findet, wo ich eigentlich immer anz, eigentlich, wo ich immer schön das Weissbier serviere, aber... Da hast du jedenfalls gut mir sagen, erklären können, wie man das isst. Dass man bei Weisswürsten die Haut auch nicht mit esse und man den Darm. Ja, absolut. Wer war der Erste, der da auf die Idee kam, ist einfach, der Darm zu benutzen dafür. Genial. Elaborated Prank einfach. Geniale Idee, aber auch. Man stelle sich vor, man hätte irgendwas anderes benutzt, dann würde die Wurst heute anders aussehen. Unvorstellbar. Absolut unvorstellbar. Da hätte man ja auch statt in den Darm irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in die Nase schieben können oder halt in die Leber oder irgend sowas, dann wäre das halt eher so ein Fladen. I Darm ist eine gute Idee. Darm ist eine geniale Idee. Aber auch eklig, dass man sagt, man häckselt das Tier klein, um dann, warum hat man überhaupt entschieden, den Darm aufzuheben? Na gut, lustige Form. Aber da hat man das Tier klein gehäckselt und steckt es dann in dessen Darm. Das ist die ultimative Demütigung eines Tieres eigentlich. Ist es dann oft, glaubst du, sehr konkrete Frage jetzt, aber in wie viel Prozent aller Würste, die du jemals gegessen hast, war das gleiche Tier in dem Darm, was den Darm besessen hat? Ach so. Hm, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich gebe die mal weiter an den Metzgereiverband in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Wenn ich eine Talkshow hätte, das wären die Fragen, die ich stellen würde. Nicht so, was haben sie sich gedacht bei dem neuen Buchstil. Nein, wie viel Prozent der Würste, die sie mit dem Leben gegessen haben, hatten anwesend sind Andi Scheuer, Anke Engelke und Olaf Scholz. Und du fragst, jetzt mal wirklich eine ehrliche Antwort. Wie viele Würste haben Sie schon gegessen, in der dieselbe Schwein sowohl Inhalt als auch Darm war? Genau. Und ich möchte keine ausweichenden Antworten. Herr Scholz. Naja, also in meiner Politik, nein! Herr Scholz, ich stelle hier eine Frage, ich werde nicht eher diese Sendung beenden, bevor Sie diese Frage beantworten haben. Der Redakteur macht schon diese Kopfabgeste und sagt so, nee, du bist nicht ... Das Publikum macht die Kopfabgeste, wenn das Publikum versucht einzugreifen und sagt, Herr Lanz, Herr Lanz, Herr Lanz, Herr Lanz, pst! Nein, nein. In wie viel Prozent der Fälle? Schliess die Türen, schliess den Notausgang, wir bleiben hier, bis die Frage beantwortet ist. Nein, bleib hier, hey, hey, hey, pack ihn am Arm, lassen Sie mich los. Aber ich will auch nicht, dass du jetzt ausweicht mit diesem lustigen Bit. Ne, ne, ne, aber vor allem auch eine andere Frage könnte zum Beispiel sein, wie viele Schweine sind in einer Wurst? Ja, das ist eine ähnliche Frage. Das ist eine Anschlussfrage. Weil dann könnte man die Wahrscheinlichkeit näher benennen, wenn jetzt in einer Wurst 60.000 Schweine sind. Also 60.000 Schweine werden... Und Erdnüsse. Eine Erd eine Erdnuss hat es geschafft. Hat sich reingeschlichen. Als Schwein verkleidet hat es in die Schlachterei geschafft. Bis heute absolut unklar, wie das passiert ist und warum. Und seitdem muss überall stehen, keine Spur von Nüssen. Genau. 60.000 Schweine in einer Wurst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ja extrem hoch, dass der Darm einem dieser Schweine gehört. Eines Schweines, das sel anderen stolz ist. Gut, dann schreien wir die Frage für dich um. Von wie vielen Prozent aller Würste, glaubst du, war exklusiv der Darmbesitzer im Darm? Exklusiv? Ja, nur der Darmbesitzer. Das glaube ich nämlich nicht. Von so einer guten Schlachterei. Naja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auf so einem Mini-Bauernhof, der ein Schwein hat oder so. Oder sogar sogar so einen Namen, Rudi. Ja, vielleicht sowas. Gut, dass mir Rudi einfällt, rennt von Rudi Rüssel. Mein Gehirn ist auch einfach basic as fuck. Ja, gut. Aber es funktioniert. Sorry, ich will mich entschuldigen. Hey, mal runter. Ich habe keine Chance, kein Schwein. Mal runter von deinem Wurst. Ich habe die beste Wurstfrage aller Zeiten erfunden, Trip. Komm mal wieder runter zu uns, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, diesem Satz. Weniger Schweine werden zu Dermen als zu Breed, das kann man so sagen, das ist fundiert. Ich kenne das Wort Breed, glaube ich nicht. Du brauchst ja ein Schwein, hat ja 60 Kilometer Darm. Das sind ja 4000 Würste. Dafür brauchst du 20 Schweine. Das heißt, das Verhältnis Darmschwein zu Brätschwein ist 1 zu 20. Das stimmt. Das heißt, pro 20 geschlachteten Schweine sind 19 Därme nutzlos. Würdest du als Schwein lieber zum Darm oder lieber zum Brät werden? Nee, schon zum Brät. Ich will ja schön mit so einer vorgefertigten Phosphormischung dann irgendwie schön reingepresst werden. Es gibt ja heute noch nicht mehr so viel Naturdarm, mein Gott, Stefan. Ja, ne? Tut doch jetzt nicht so, als gäbe es da noch irgendwie schön feinen Naturdarm. Naturdarm. Ist ja auch eine Weisswurst, glaube ich, würde man schon eher ... Da ist eh noch ganz anderer Scheiss drin. Weiß auch kein Mensch, warum die so aussieht. Weiß niemand. Warum die weiss ist? Weiß auch niemand. Niemand weiss es? Niemand. Ich glaube, das wusste mal jemand, aber er ist mittlerweile gestorben. Er ist mittlerweile in den Fleischwolf gefallen und wurde selbst zu weissem Fleisch. Und auch das konnte sich niemand erklären. Und das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Viele offene Rätsel eigentlich auch. Ja, so ein Fleischwolf, oder? Du isst ja gar kein Fleisch mehr. Nein, aber ich habe trotzdem Interesse an einem Fleischwolf, einfach alles zusammenzumaschen. Man kann ja auch andere Sachen da reinstecken. Ja, es ist ja eigentlich, irgendwie hat ein Fleischwolf viel, viel mehr Kraft als ein Mixer irgendwie. Es gab dieses Jucke und Klaas-Duell um die Welt-Thema, ein Einspieler über Blutwurst, illegale Blutwurst mit Eigenblut. So, klingt furchtbar. Im Endeffekt war es aber nur, war es irgendwie ein illegaler Verein in China, irgendwo in so einer Nebengasse in Shanghai, keine Ahnung. Und dann haben die aber nur zwei Tropfen Blut von der Empfindung oder so genommen. Und haben das dann in die Blutwurst aufgepackt. Untergemischt, unter dem ganzen Rinderblut. Gimmick. So. Und die haben es nicht gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, wer da die Aufgabe bekommen hat, aber er hat es nicht gemacht. Und war so ein Riesenthema und das Kannibalismus und bla bla bla. Und es ist auch illegal, selbst in China ist es illegal. Und ich dachte mir, ich würde es sofort machen. Ja, da hätte ich aber auch kein Problem damit. Gar kein Problem damit. Ist das für Veganer dann aber ein Problem, wenn ich mich gefragt? Eigenblut? Ist das ein Problem, das sich selten stellt, Kannibalismus, ganz ehrlich, aber die vegane Community ist da gespalten. Ich drifte ein bisschen ab in meinen Fragen. Die vegane Community ist da gespalten, viele sagen, greift zu, biete ihn nicht, legt ihn den Teller voll. Ist Kannibalismus unter Veganern erlaubt? Solange das Objekt gut behandelt wird und es so ein gutes Leben hatte, kann man das, glaube ich, verargumentieren. Okay. Aber ich glaube insgesamt schon, weil sonst müsste auch so was wie Muttermilch und so was dann schwierig werden. Aber ich glaube, ich meine, du hast ja jetzt eine Prise Humor in diese Frage gewürzt und jetzt bist dir bewusst, dass das nicht ganz klar ist. Aber ich hätte da auch nicht unbedingt Probleme, eigenes Blut zu trinken. Ich meine, das macht man ja ab und zu, aus Versehen auch so, wenn man Zahnfleischbluten hat oder so. Habe ich tatsächlich, ich dachte mir so, ich hätte Bock eigentlich, weil ich habe, manchmal steigt man ja in so medizinische Gruselmärchen ab, dann irgendwie so Zahnfleisch wund und das Zahnfleisch haut ab und das wächst nie wieder. Vorhin freut mich. Und das wächst nie wieder nach und so und wenn das einmal weg ist, dann hat man verloren und dann denkt man sich so, ja das ist schon echt nicht cool. schon echt nicht cool. Paradontose? Ja, irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung. Und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, und dann heißt es auch so, man darf nicht mit zu harten Zahnbürsten, Zähnebürsten und ich habe immer hart, weil ich mir dachte, ich will so hart, es geht Zähnebürsten. Könnt ihr mal so eine Liste machen, so eine große Exel-Tabelle, wo steht hart weich. Was soll Hart jetzt sein, was weich? Weil Matratzen ist auch so ... Hattuch, rau oder sanft. Ja, aber nee, das ist eine andere Liste, rau oder sanft, aber hart oder weich, weil irgendwann bei Matratzen hieß es, nee, weich ist total gut, irgendwann war, nee, hart ist für die Wirbelsäule viel besser. Ich will eine Liste. Stuhl, Rückenstuhl oder irgendwie sowas. Ich will die endgültige Liste, wo steht Hart-Weich und dann alles erklärt. Zahnbürste, dann steht das bei hart oder bei weich. Gerne, leg gerne ein Google-Dokument an. Ich kann Command-F drücken. Kannst du ein Google-Dokument öffnen und die Podcast-Community füllt diese Liste mit hart, weich, was soll hart sein, was soll weich sein, Wasser, hart, weich, Schuhsohle, hart, weich, Boden, alles. Was ist besser hart weich und dann einfach die endgültige Liste. Ich will Command F drücken können und jedes beliebige Wort eingeben können. Und es zeigt mir, ob es in der Hart- oder Weichliste steht. Ja, und vor allem dann auch, warum gibt es denn überhaupt eine Auswahl? Weil dann hat da irgendwie so ein Blog Zahnarzt geschrieben, ja, man darf nicht zu harte Zahnbürsten nehmen. Wo ich mir denke, warum gibt es denn dann harte Zahnbürsten? Kann da nicht mal jemand irgendwie drauf gucken? Und dann habe ich mir eine schöne weichere Zahnbürste geholt und extra so Zahnpasta, die so mit extra so Zahnfleisch gedönst hat. Und dann habe ich mir damit die Zähne geputzt, anscheinend zu eifrig, dass mein Zahnfleisch angefangen hat zu bluten, von dieser Anti-Zahnblutungs-Zahnpasta, was ich hochikonisch fand. Weil du überkompensiert hast vielleicht. Mein lautes Lachen sprühte Blut durch mein ganzes Badezimmer. Ich habe mich scheckig gelacht und habe wirklich wie so ein Gartensprenger mein komplettes Badezimmer, meine Zähne, wirklich. 32 kleine Blutfontänen schossen Blut aus meinem Mund und es war ein... So ein grosser Spaß, ein grosses Fest. Es war ein Fest, es hat Spaß gemacht, es hat höllisch wehgetan und hat mich dann langsam auch in den Blutverlustschlaf fallen lassen. Ich bin aufgewacht in der Blutlache und dann hat er mir angefangen zu lachen. Das ist ja alles ein grosser Quatsch. Aber genau wie dieses, was ich auch nicht verstanden habe, bei Oral B oder so, oder Doktor Oetker, ich weiß, die andere Firma, Doktor Benz oder sowas. Onkel Benz. Onkel Benz. Naja, irgendwer, irgendein Onkel, Doktor, keine Ahnung. Da gab es doch am Ende dann immer das Logo von der Firma und dann gab es diese Tomate und dann hat jemand diese Zahnbürste an die Tomate geklischt und hat die so leicht nachgegeben. Und das war immer so, als Kind dachte ich immer, ja wow, das ist die perfekte Zahnbürste. Warum? Für Tomaten, aber was ist mit Menschen? Aber was sagt mir das jetzt? Ja, das sagt ja anscheinend, es fällt jetzt genau in diese Kerbe, dass Zahnbürsten müssen weich sein. Ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht, aber der ist so leicht nachgegeben und die Tomate wurde so leicht auch eingedrückt. Also entweder es zeigt dieses Gelenk, dieses Zahnbürstengelenk, im Sinne von, ah guck mal, die gibt nach, schon bei niedriger Belastung. Schon bei Tomaten. Oder es soll zeigen, wie viele Tausende Tomaten dafür herhalten mussten für Zahnpastawerbung und für Messerwer, Messer-Werbung werden immer an Tomaten getestet. Ja, ich nehme immer, das ist aber auch, die sind nicht hart, also die sind nicht schwierig durchzumachen. Naja, aber die Haut ist schon manchmal tricky. Ich würde gerne Papier und dann oben so in Papier rein. Ja, das gibt es auch, obwohl mir das auch nichts sagt. Aber tatsächlich, hat da mal irgendjemand drauf geachtet, wie viel Prozent aller Tomaten für Messer- und Zahnbürstenwerbung unnötig weggeworfen werden eigentlich? Hat da immer jemand ein Auge drauf? Ja, lass uns mal, ohne Scheiß, die Tomaten wurden ein bisschen vergessen und zurückgelassen von uns als Gesellschaft. Was ist da los, wie viele da weggeschmissen wurden, als ob da jemand daneben ist. Ja, und auch bei so wütenden Demonstrationen. Was wird geworfen? Die Tomate. Ja, bei wütenden, bei den schlechten Theaterstücken. Was wird geworfen? Tomate. Ja, Tenet, ich habe den filmlich verstanden. Was fliegt auf die Leinwand? Tomate. Immer eine mit dabei. Weintraum. Und meine Jacke habe ich geworfen. Ja, das tut mir leid. Das tut mir leid. Es war ein emotionaler Ausbruch, egal. Aber ja. Warum sollte man eine Jacke, die fliegt nicht weit. Ich fahre mir gerade, wie lustig es wäre, wenn jemand mehr so eine Jacke will, weil er nichts zu werfen hat. Weil es gibt gerade auch viele Momente, wo irgendwie bei Shakespeare damals oder sowas schlechte Aufführungen und links um einen herum holen alle so Obst raus und werfen das und man denkt, da hat so nichts mitgebracht. Ja.. Wie oft habe ich meinen Schlüssel vergessen, wie oft vergesse ich mein Handy. Ja, klar. Und dann fuck, ah. Dann hat man nichts und dann wirft man seine Jacke, einen Hoodie. Die dann wirklich sich wie so ein Fallschirm aufstülpt. Ganz schnell, also feilschnell anfängt und dann wapp und dann sofort wie so eine unsichtbare Wand und dann runterfliegt. Und dann runterfällt. So ein bisschen der Joe-Bluth-Moment, wo er versucht, den Brief ins Meer zu werfen. Und es einfach nicht funktioniert, weil man den Brief einfach nicht gut werfen kann. Man kann als Deutsche in Resident Development nicht referenzieren. Joe-Bluth ist sehr schwierig, also in so einem Gag kurz einzuflechten. Zu viele Gs und THs. Aber teuer Moment. Viele kennen wahrscheinlich nur das GIF von jemandem, der einen Brief ins Meer wirft. Das ist der Moment. Kann man nicht, ne? Fliegt weird. Fliegt weird und wind. Mehr ist es oft windig. Schwer irgendwas effektvoll ins Meer zu werfen. Aber manchmal habe ich tatsächlich echt Lust. Also ich sehe irgendwie, keine Ahnung bei mir, ich habe noch einen Stuhl, den ich nicht brauche und ich denke mir so, wer fehlt jetzt mehr? Kristall sitzt auf meiner Schulter und sagt, wer fehlt jetzt mehr? Was sagt jetzt der Bruder? Ja, hallo, oh da kommt er, Herr Tal, hallo. Hey, sorry, du musst hier rein, wir arbeiten hier so semi. Wir sind bald fertig. Kristall klopft mir an die Schulter und sagt, wer fehlt jetzt mehr? Niemand wird im Meer danach suchen. Wer findet das Meer? Und dann denke ich mir, geht der unter? Oder wird der schwimmen? Darf ich das? Wie lange? Und was sagt Heselbrocker? Heselbrocker hat mittlerweile einen besseren Podcast gefunden und bessere Leute, mit denen sie abhängt. Comedypreis, die ist mittlerweile ganz woanders. Die ist komplett woanders. Warum gewinnt die dann in dem ersten Jahr, wo man dann nicht da ist, gewinnt dann Hazel Brugger einen Comedypreis? Das ist immer was Cooles. Ich glaube, hat sie nicht auch getwittert, dass sie schwanger ist? Falls das stimmt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, falls das nicht ein Gag ist. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das heißt, unser allergutes Gewissen ist jetzt auf auf Schwangerschaftsurlaub. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt erstmal ein richtiges Problem, weil Kristall jetzt ohne Widerrede Einfluss nehmen kann. Unser Engel ist im Schwangerschaftsurlaub. Unser Engel ist weg. Das heißt, irgendwann denke ich mir so, du mietest dir jetzt in Kartugau, haust den Stuhl da rein, fährst an die Ostsee. Nee, du kannst es einfach abschliessen. Und das ist nicht mehr das. Genial. In Car2Go stecken ist ja das neue im Meer versenken. Eigentlich schon, ja. Ich dachte mir, das war mal eine Idee für so einen Kurzfilm vom Kumpel. Der hat gesagt, wenn man so Studenten jemanden umbringen, und dann stecken die den Car2Go und dann schliessen die das Car2Go ab. Genial. Ausser, dass Car2Go weiss, wer es war. Aber die dürfen es nicht sagen, weil in dieser Welt hat Car2Go so eine Schweigepflicht. Und es geht in Saturn nicht, aber das ist ein anderer. Und es spielt in Palermo, wo es eigentlich keine Car2Go gibt, aber da müsste man dann halt die umlackieren, dass da Palermo auch noch draufsteht. Es ist schwierig. Drehbuchstreiben ist eine Kunst. Es ist wirklich eine Kunst. Ich habe mich auch schon gefragt, warum nicht viel mehr von diesen Mietrollern einfach in den Reihen geworfen wurden. Weil da stehen so viele rum, so viel im Weg und es gibt so viele Leute, die schimpfend
daran vorbeilaufen, wo ich mir denke, dann wirf ich den Rhein. Also natürlich, nein, natürlich nicht. Dann wirf ich den Rhein rein. Aber die stehen direkt am Ufer, Hunderte, und Leute kommen da und, oh Gott, das ist hässlich, das ist so nichts mehr. Dann wirfst in Rhein. Sehr konkret, auch in Hamburg stimmst du und sagst, ja dann wirf's in Rhein.
Dann miets, fahr nach Köln und wirf's in Rhein.
Weil ich denke mir, das ist ja unmöglich nachzuh- also jetzt wirklich macht das nicht, Leute, ihr wisst, alles Ironie, aber das ist ja unmöglich nachzuverfolgen.
Aber generell ist das in Köln eigentlich ein guter Satz, ja dann wirf's halt in Rhein.
Ja, beschwer dich nicht, wirf es in den Rhein, wenn es dich so stört.
Ja, gar nicht, ob diese Roller, das ist auch albern, weil Roller machen das Stadtbild ja nicht hässlicher.
Wir haben uns einfach nur so an Autos gewöhnt, überall stehen Autos, überall und die sind hässlich, überall stehen die rum, blockieren alles,
aber wir sind aufgewachsen in einer Welt, wo überall Autos rumstehen, deswegen ist es okay, und dann kommen plötzlich diese Roller auf,
Das ist ein Schiff. Überall, und die sind hässlich, überall stehen die rum, blockieren alles, aber wir sind aufgewachsen in einer Welt, wo überall Autos rumstehen, deswegen ist es okay, und dann kommen plötzlich diese Roller auf, sind viel kleiner, sind viel, viel weniger, ein Bruchteil, und wir regen uns darüber auf, weil die das Stadtbild ruinieren, weil die mit dem hässlichen Klacklio rumstehen, oder was? Aber auch weil sie mehr im Weg stehen als Autos. Du läufst halt, du läufst über die Hohenzollernbrücke und mitten im Weg, mitten im Fussgängerübergang über die Hohenzollernbrücke. Ja, dann wirf ihn halt den Reim! Ja, und ich denke mir so, wirklich, es ist eins plus eins, der steht im Weg und wirklich 40 Zentimeter daneben fließt einer der größten Flüsse Deutschlands. Fließt die Lösung! Ja, sie rauscht, du hörst sie schon, sie schreit, wirf ihn in mich. Kristall erscheint als Wassernympfe unten im Rhein, als Rheintall, schreibt er, wirf ihn in mich, wirf ihn in mich. Und dass da nicht jemand sagt, so nachts, drei Uhr nachts, wo niemand da ist, wirf dieses Ding einfach da rein, macht's nicht. und ich will jetzt nicht Köln-Kurier-Artikel Florentin Will stiftet zum Reinwurf an. Der Reinwurf! Reinfall. Scheiße, die Schlagzeile. Großer Reinfall. Der große Reinfall. Verdammt, die Schlagzeile ist zu schmissig, die wird so geschrieben werden. Macht das nicht. Zu gut. Na ja. Man kann das nachverfolgen. Aber ich finde das... Aber ich denke mir... Ich finde trotzdem, dass der Satz, den sollten wir etablieren in Köln, ja dann wirfst halt hin rein. So muss man ja, dann mach halt was dagegen. Das finde ich trotzdem gut. Also unabhängig macht's nicht. Oder macht's... Aber es ist zumindest... Nein, aber... Du wirst völlig recht. Nein, wirfst halt hin rein. Ja. Wenn es dich stört, wirfst halt hin rein. Hakuna Matata. Das ist ja das Hakuna Matata von Köln. Mach was, mach was, greif dein Leben selbst. Motz nicht die ganze Zeit rum, sondern mach was dagegen. Ja. Und wenn du nichts dagegen machst, dann beschwer dich auch nicht. Nee, wirf halt den rein. So, so. Wir werden uns nächste Woche ... Wir haben uns beruhigt, wir kommen jetzt runter. Wir haben viel geschafft heute, wir haben viel geschafft. Wir haben viel, wir haben die Zahnfleisch, die ultimative Liste. Könnt ihr euch ja anhören. Darum könnt ihr noch mal reinhören. Wir brauchen nicht zusammenfassen. Warum soll es zusammenfassen? Warum soll es am Ende die Zusammenfassung nicht? Das macht ja Sinn. Wir haben das Gegenteil von dem Tuan-Duo. Ciao, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche. Wir heben ab Wehem ab im Balance. Wir machen was mit uns?
Wir beeilen uns.
Ach so.
Es ist total schwierig, sich in Abmoderation, it's a voice by production.